how you doing people it is friday march
4th in the year 2022 i'm dave rubin this
is the ruben report direct message we
are live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv do me a favor and subscribe i
think i've mentioned that once or twice
you've probably done it already but why
not double check because you never know
what our big tech overlords are doing to
us uh and before we get to the
reubenreport.locals.com q a today we're
going to talk a little bit about a beef
a growing beef between elon musk
and joe biden and i also want to remind
you guys that you can now pre-order
don't burn this country which is my
second book it is coming out on april
12th
just about 40 days from now uh i think
you're gonna dig it it's sort of the
next step
after don't burn this book it's the next
steps in how you can take more control
of your life how we can sort of get off
the crazy train that these people have
put us on and what you can do to empower
yourself and not only survive but as the
subtitle says thrive in our woke
dystopia okay though let's start off
with uh elon musk and joe biden elon
musk of course spacex
tesla the boring company this is a guy
who's a true innovator one of the
founders originally of paypal along with
peter thiel this is someone who has done
more extraordinary
innovation technologically
scientifically in terms of production
just everything that we do he's not
happy with joe biden and joe biden is a
elderly man who's pretending to be
president who's been around in office uh
roughly 48 years in public life and
hasn't accomplished that much and who
pretty much lies for a living so they're
fighting and uh i thought it would be an
interesting way to kick off the show
today uh here's some info from zero
hedge elon musk tweeted at the president
on tuesday night criticizing him for not
mentioning tesla during his state of the
union address during the address
president biden made mention of a
combined 18 billion
in investments made into electric
vehicles by ford and general motors
combined tesla was once again not
mentioned
by the president
then
during the state of the union itself joe
biden has someone else tweeting for him
and now that's generally fine usually
they've got
interns or pr people or
associates and assistants whatever it
might be the thing is with joe biden and
his twitter account it's like it's
obviously never him but anyway during
the state of the union the official joe
biden account tweeted this
ford is investing 11 billion to build
electric vehicles creating 11 000 jobs
across the country gm is making the
largest investment in its history 7
billion to build electric vehicles
creating 4 000
jobs in michigan
while elon musk felt that he was getting
slighted and he tweeted this
at joe himself he wrote tesla has
created over 50 000 u.s jobs building
electric vehicles and investing more
than double gm
and ford combined fyi to person
controlling this twitter there's a
little little needle for you joe we know
it's not you like orange man that was
that guy behind the uh the twitter
screen uh zerohedge has a little more on
this the white house said it was worried
musk would be a bad guest and would say
something to embarrass the
administration if he was ever invited
onto the premises musk responded to the
report by telling cnbc they have nothing
to worry about i would do the right
thing in late january the tesla ceo
referred to biden as a damp sock puppet
in human form in a twitter tirade he
published in late january biden is
treating the american public like fools
he later tweeted nobody is watching the
state of the union musk told cnbc in an
email wednesday biden has pointedly
ignored tesla musk has told cnbc in the
past so the reason i thought this one
was interesting was because with all of
the craziness going on right
the war
that they invented out of nowhere and
the end of kovid although now they're
putting masks back on people and more
mandates or something like that and
supply chains and all of the stuff um
biden going out of his way
not to mention tesla he doesn't have to
say elon musk's name okay fine you can
put aside the ego for a second on that
elan but like to not mention tesla that
has created these 50 000 jobs on top of
spacex which is going to send us to mars
and beyond it's like this is a private
company that does get some subsidies and
tax
breaks to do some of this stuff but this
is a private company that's not only
building an underground his boring
companies building an underground
system for futuristic cars to go under
los angeles not that anyone will live in
los angeles by the time it's done but
he's doing that the tesla is a freaking
awesome
awesome car actually my producer michael
sitting over there got his tesla this
week had two thumbs up two thumbs up for
the tesla okay uh yeah it's awesome uh
it it clearly is like hands above right
like it's just like leaps beyond any
other electric car at the moment so
biden is just creating an unnecessary
fight here but it does sort of make
sense like if you think the government
is supposed to do everything right then
you don't like people who kind of do
things you don't like people who
actually innovate you want everyone to
be part of the government machine and
elon musk refuses to do that elon musk
by the way who took tesla out of
california because of high taxes
moved them to austin texas now he's not
getting any income tax
of course in
texas austin though is becoming sort of
a blue dystopia in its own way so
they're going to have to deal with that
anyway i mentioned all this because i
think it's just good to see some
industrialists and innovators fighting
against government nonsense and on that
note let's get to a reuben report
community q a
kerry says how did it come about that so
many americans agreed to hate america is
there a unique evil genius yeah you know
it's a good one because so much of this
sort of starts with that so much of the
destruction of everything that we know
is good right equal rights equality in
the true sense of equality that everyone
has come here
i always say it but it's man think about
your grand parents think about what your
great-grandparents whoever your
ancestors were that came here whether
they came on the mayflower or they came
on a boat from venezuela or they came
and eventually uh you know got to the
lower east side in new york or whatever
they did whether they were you know
prospecting going west to find gold like
everyone's ancestors who came here came
here for a better life and almost every
single case
of it it turned out to be that way and
their children had it better their
grandchildren had it better everything
else we have such extraordinary goodness
here and we're just on the cusp of
giving it away and that's the catch-22
of good times good times create weak men
right and then weak men create bad times
and then bad times create strong men and
then the good times that they bring
start creating weak men you get it like
that's just how it is and we've had such
an incredible run of good times that we
all sort of became weak within that and
and i think
you know the silver lining to everything
that's happened over these last two
three years is a lot of us are looking
in the mirror we're trying to
you know sort of figure out what
mistakes we made along the way and and
really think about life in a new way and
there is a new horizon guys there really
is like it ain't gonna be easy to get
there and it could still get much worse
but there are places that are fighting
for things the right way have i said
anything about the state of florida
lately like there really really are but
uh
how did it happen how did we all end up
hating this place
it's everything they won the culture war
and then they made us feel guilty for
freedom and goodness and success and you
should never feel guilty about that you
know if someone grows up in a decent
family with parents that work hard and
love them and take care of them in their
middle class or dare i say upper middle
class or even upper class you have to be
somehow shamed of that right we only
love the story of the person who came
from nothing and they had nothing and
they were abused and then they had less
than nothing and less than that but it's
like you should be very proud if your
parents busted their butts to give you a
good life and most likely your
grandparents did before that i talk
about that in my first book like that's
my life is the is the american dream my
great-grandparents came here with
nothing my grandparents were lower
middle class my parents got to to middle
class maybe upper middle class i've done
pretty well i hope that when we have
kids that they'll do even better than me
and that you don't forget all the
traditions and all the good stuff along
the way so we got work to do but yeah
they somehow they somehow put a a virus
in the system to make a lot of people
hate probably the most beautiful
experiment in human history brim says
dave how's the new house coming love to
get some decor
tips so it's coming along it's taken
some time uh because of the supply chain
stuff like we're just trying to get
stuff we want to put a little wood on
the walls one thing that we're having
right now i don't know if you could
actually hear it do you think they could
hear it clyde was barking his brains out
about 30 seconds ago which we're also
getting a trainer for clyde he's sort of
lost some of his training since we got
to florida i think it's the lizards
everywhere uh the iguanas and everything
um but so we want to get some like wood
on the walls and some stuff to deal with
some of the sound because there's like a
big echo in the main part of the house
but it is coming together you know not
all of our furniture matched this house
exactly we have a lot of wall space here
actually one thing that i can ask you
guys we have a huge wall here like
really high ceilings like 20 foot high
ceilings in the main room that it's
probably like 15 foot wide that wide
that i've got nothing on i would love
to get an awesome
vintage american flag that we could
frame i'm talking massive like massive
massive american flag i don't know
exactly where to get one can you hear
clyde right now or how is our sound
proofing because he's going nuts right
now um
so uh decor tips you know we like modern
stuff but we like some industrial stuff
and we try to keep it warm and we got a
bunch of candles around and uh yeah
we're doing our thing but we're getting
there and uh you know hopefully the the
supply chain stuff gets solved and some
of the things that we've been ordering
you know we're trying to build the new
studio downstairs everything just takes
time we're trying to put a big window in
the guy said to get a window it's going
to take four months to get one window
it's like what thank you
brandon
steve says with all that's happening
right now around the world in our in our
own country is there a topic that you've
not been able to cover because
everything else has been gobbled and
gobbling up the air time this is a great
question so one thing that you know we
talk about
in sort of distant ways or it bounces
around because it touches a lot of the
woke stuff and the crt stuff is i want
to do more on school choice
generally speaking you know obviously
the big thing around that was that glenn
young won the governor's race in
virginia and that was a real pushback by
the parents to get critical race out of
schools that's to get it out of public
schools but i really want to do more on
this idea of funding students instead of
systems i think this is really what the
future of education is in america is
going to be i don't think we should have
a department of education at this point
i don't think a federal department that
is supposed to tell students from all
over the world and teachers and
ultimately parents what these kids are
supposed to be learning it just doesn't
make sense anymore especially because
woke-ism has absolutely infected
everything uh i think that if you're
going to have any tax dollars go to
education and i suppose as long as we're
going to have taxes that's a whole other
discussion about taxes but if we are
going to have any tax money meaning the
government is going to take money from
you and then pick what to do with it i
don't think it should be giving it to a
system i think it should be giving it
back to you
so that you can decide what do you want
to do with that do you want to send your
kid to the to the public school do you
want to send them to the charter school
that maybe is a little bit more money
and then you have to put more money in
do you want to homeschool them there's
these pods now all of these things i
just think it's so important because to
link this to the first question how had
this get so bad how'd they get these bad
ideas and how they teach so many people
to hate america
it had a little something to do with
schools
tracy says how's clyde adjusting to the
florida heat well at the moment he's
he's doing it right this i i don't know
i don't know if you could quite hear it
but he's barking his brains out right
now he's been killing squirrels
and iguanas and lizards he's having a
ball but we did actually just this
morning
we brought in a new dog trainer uh
because clyde was a rescue
uh for those of you that don't know we
got clyde the first day of the lockdown
in los angeles i i you know as
everything was locking down and everyone
was running to the stores to get food i
saw this thing on twitter about los
angeles shelters they were going to kill
all the all these dogs because they
didn't have people to take care of them
and they were going to put all these
dogs down
and emma our our previous dog who we
just adored and she had just passed away
at 16 a few weeks before we wanted a
little break but i was like i can't just
let them kill all these dogs and i just
ran to the shelter
and i saw clyde in there he was in a
he's he's a boxer and a pit he's pretty
big dog he was being terrorized by a
little chihuahua in a dress i'm not
kidding a trans chihuahua
was barking his brains at his or her or
whatever brain at clyde
and he had a big scar on his head that
we've since he got surgery for but he
was very timid and i was like he looked
sort of like emma and i was just like
that's our guy we're taking him and he
already had they had signed the papers
he was going to be put down right then
and there uh they had signed the papers
but we saved him he's good anyway he's
been a little nutty since we've been
here i think the the you know there's
more animals out here we've got peacocks
outside we've got a lot of windows here
so anyway we're getting him retrained
and i think i think he will be okay and
as as per the heat you know we take we
try to go for two nice walks a day with
him uh and it is hot and humid sometimes
and he he seems to be doing just fine
and i've made it clear to him you're not
allowed to complain about florida so
that's the most important thing
uh phil says hey dave i too am a recent
florida transplant from michigan
congratulations and you don't have to
deal with whitmer anymore and loving it
every day ain't it grand to be free i
think what everyone wants to know is
what position you will be accepting in
president desantis's cabinet wow well
look joking aside i i've said before
that if ben shapiro ever ran for
president and became president the one
job that i would consider
is press secretary like the thing that
jen sake does every day where she just
goes up there and lies to all of those
people i would love
and by the way it wouldn't last too long
something would go horrifically awry but
for two weeks of that job to get up
there and rail against all those evil
lying reporters from the new york times
and the washington post and everything
else and do it kind of in a fun way and
just mocking way like that sounds a lot
of fun so look i i said i would do it
for ben i i guess i would do it for
desantis ah you know what why not if ron
desantis becomes president although once
again i just want to go on the record
i'd prefer that he's stay governor here
in florida but if ron desantis becomes
president and he taps me to be press
secretary to deal with those self-hating
freak weirdos in the press corps
i would do it like i would do it to the
best of my ability i don't think it
would end well but i would give it a go
but you know ron stay
gov stay here
fortify the place then we'll see what
happens yuri says when you go back to la
do you think you will view the city in a
different way after living in florida so
if you weren't watching the show
yesterday you may not know that what
you're watching right now
is actually pre-recorded from yesterday
i'm coming to you from the past right
now even though you think it's the
present because i'm in los angeles right
this very moment i had to take a flight
very early friday morning to go directly
to the prageru offices to tape my fourth
prageru video which will coincide with
the release of don't burn this country
so the new video is sort of based off
the ideas of the book and i'm going to
la to do that and then i am getting the
hell out of there real quick
real quick um i'm not looking forward to
it i'm really not just the idea of
getting there and breathing that air
again and seeing the miserable people
with the mess and the thing
it just doesn't seem fun to me i guess
maybe i'll drive by my house and my old
house and say hi to the house but like i
don't miss anything about it i really
don't like you know i we had good
friends there and a lot of them actually
are enroute to moving here to florida
right now or going a lot of them are
going to nashville as well a couple in
uh texas dallas area mostly but i really
just
don't miss
anything
about la i don't uh elizabeth says how
does rumble's platform differ from
youtube's and what inspired you to use
this site
so rumble you know it's interesting a
lot of people think that rumble is just
a youtube replacement meaning just like
a forward-facing video website where you
just search videos and you get videos
and you watch them and the player is
clean and all that kind of stuff
really what rumble as a company is is
much more than that because they're
really working on an amazon aws
replacement aws amazon web services and
as i've discussed with you guys before
that's sort of the underbelly of the
internet when parlor got blown offline
after january 6 and and the big tech
companies just did a coordinated mafia
hit on parlor it was because they were
using amazon aws and basically someone
at amazon just had to click a button or
touch a touch screen or pull a lever and
just blow apart their website just like
that so it showed a real uh weakness
in our ability to stay online so rumble
is working on real aws replacement stuff
so that websites just won't be able to
be blown up just like that that's one
thing
the other thing of course you know i
created locals a couple of years ago
really at first as a patreon replacement
and then we realized wow there's a whole
feature of suites that we can
give or a whole suite of features i
should say that we should give to
creators so that they own their content
and they can get live chat out and text
chat and all of these things that we're
now doing and push notifications and own
your data and on your your user
information things of that nature
locals ultimately
was merged with rumble and i really
believe these are the these are the uh
tracks the alternate tracks of the
internet if there's going to be a free
internet
i don't know that we could do it but we
are trying and we've got great people
we've got great investors we've got
great engineers and actually i should
give a shout out to a whole bunch of our
programmers who are in ukraine right now
as far as i know
at least at the moment if we're taping
this everyone is safe but people have
been fleeing it has not been easy we're
trying to figure out other ways that we
can help everybody
um
but
i think that rumble and locals it's the
best chance we got to get off the the
big tech stuff so i know obviously most
of you still watch this on youtube but i
would welcome you to just subscribe over
at rumble.com
ruben report and start checking the show
over there and of course
reubenreport.locals.com where you can
interact with me a little more directly
janet says do you ever feel like some of
the insane things the left says they
actually believe or do you think they're
lying you know it goes to that sort of
intentions thing which we're always
talking about here it's like
some of them were believers right like
real believers like i believe
that bernie sanders believes the
nonsense that he says like he just he is
a socialist at heart he believes in a
big system that he who's never created
anything that he can create some sort of
system above all of us
that will govern us all properly even
though bernie has never created anything
like he created a couple political
campaigns where people just give him
money it's a great gig for a socialist
right
but he's never created a business bernie
never really created anything of value
he's been a politician forever that's
not a creation that's to me that's not
an accomplishment aoc becoming a
politician is not an accomplishment it's
like oh you got a bunch of people to
give you money and then the media liked
you so then you started having power
over people
bernie never created a restaurant you
know hired people balanced the payroll
et cetera et cetera i've done more of
that than bernie sanders
many of you watching this have done far
more of that than almost all of you
watching this unless your politicians
have done more than bernie sanders in
that regard but i would say bernie is a
believer in socialism the idea of
socialism to me socialism and the idea
that humans create can create a system
that is better than us
and is actually uh
that will that will enable us to be
better than than we are as individuals i
just don't believe it i just don't
believe it i think it's i think it's
anti-human actually uh so what you want
to do i think is to empower people the
most they can then from the ground up
they can create communities which is why
people go to church into temple and
things like that and then you can sort
of build up from there so i think you
have your real believers and then you i
think have just the confused masses and
i think this is what this actually gets
back to that first question i was asked
about evil and how did they get so many
people to hate america it's like
you get all of these people you teach
them all of these bad ideas that all
sort of sound right it's why leftism
spreads so easily while the ideas of
freedom don't spread as easily leftism
spreads easily because it all sounds
right oh
we want tolerance and and it's like yes
we all want tolerance of course everyone
wants tolerance everyone wants doesn't
want people to be bigoted in all of
those things
but to get rid of all of the bad things
in in humanity or have to get rid of a
lot of people and that's why socialists
end up end up killing an awful lot of
people communists end up killing an
awful lot of people hitler pol pot et
cetera
so the believers there you got the
believers and then you've got the
confused masses and then you've got the
sort of tech part of this which is that
now we have algorithmically
charged and corporate funded movements
to push really bad ideas and why do they
push bad ideas because it's it's pretty
much ways that they can control you why
do they push mask mandates why do they
push ideas that that you know all white
people and christians are racist no one
believes any no one believed that the
masks really worked fauci himself didn't
right at the beginning you've seen the
emails nobody really believes that
america is systemically racist you have
confused people and people who are using
bad ideas to further whatever their
goals are which usually involve making
some money
ray says with the science changing and
mandates being lifted do you think that
the american people will just forget
about everything they've been put
through for the last two years and
forgive biden for all the bs look i've
been talking about this one a lot
the machine does incredible things
if you would have said to anyone a month
ago right beginning of january when
omicron had just sort of run run through
the entire country over christmas into
the new year if you would have said to
anybody boy you know when joe biden
gives his state of the union speech in a
month from now he's basically not going
to mention covet for the first half hour
and we're going to be talking about that
war in russia and ukraine the whole time
as if that's the most important thing
for the state of the american union
almost nobody would believe you but
that's how the machine operates like
they wanted to now get us off kovid and
why do they want to get us off kovid
because they know that if they've abused
us for so long that maybe some people
are getting fed up with it and are not
going to vote for them in a couple
months during the midterms
so i
you got to give them credit how they do
it how they trick and confuse people and
get people to cheer on their own abuse
of masks get people to cheer on firing
nurses get people to cheer on wars they
know nothing about
give the thing credit and know what it
is but don't forget and that's why i've
been trying to do the show the way i
have especially in the last couple weeks
don't forget who put us in this
situation you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a democrat
peter says how does the food and culture
in florida differ from the food and
culture in california well the culture
question is easily is easy i mean the
culture is just
fabulous here and wonderful and you know
there's a ton of especially in miami
where i am in in south florida
there's such a cuban and venezuelan
influence that you know you drive around
and you hear music and you hear spanish
and there's sort of a funness to it and
you get a cuban sandwich on any corner
and a lot of coffee a lot of coffee
these people love their coffee everyone
drives like complete maniacs here in
miami i think it's because it's such an
international city that you know people
just take whatever traditions they have
from the roads and the countries with
which they came and they just drive that
way and there's people just it's nuts
out here driving which is probably a
good sign that elon musk will you know
get those teslas to be fully
self-driving in cities at some point
because every idiot's still driving
around with their phone in their hand um
but the culture the culture here right
now putting aside languages and things
like that uh you know i'm somewhat
involved in the tech world so i go to a
lot of parties in that regard and it's
like the people that are coming here are
so psyched to be here
um they they want to bring other good
people here like you can just feel it um
you know i mentioned right when i got
here i went to a party and mayor suarez
was there and he came up to me and he
big hug dave we're so happy you're here
it's like they want good people here so
culturally this this place is just great
it's also hopping all the time i mean
for the first few weeks we were here we
stayed at friends on miami beach which
is just an absolute scene like over the
top scene because everybody wants to
come and party in florida much like aoc
and uh the farting guy swall will
remember him uh there's a name i haven't
mentioned in a while for good reason so
the the culture is just great here the
food scene you know we haven't gone out
that much we've only gone out to dinner
maybe once or twice we do like cooking
here and you guys know i love the
grilling um i went to hillstone david
and i went to hillstone last night which
is a chain so that's not like the most
miami thing
ever but we went to the to the local
hillstone here and i just love hillstone
it's such if you haven't been there
hillstone some of them are known as
houston's
depending uh what part of the country
you're in um they just do such a great
job and actually one of the things i
liked was they had a card at the entry
of the restaurant
and they said and it had uh the types of
things that you could wear if you were
to come into their restaurant we don't
want men coming in here with uh tank
tops we don't want you coming in with
open-toed shoes like flip-flops it was
just like you know we we treat this
place a certain way and we'd like to you
to treat it a certain way and i was like
we could use a little more of that a
little more of hey put on some good
clothes and come out and eat some good
food and the service is great and all
that good stuff but if you've got some
tips on miami restaurants we could use
them taway says what are some top
beliefs and values that you want to
teach your kids throughout their lives
so look you guys know we don't have kids
yet i'll have some updates on that
shortly uh probably more than i should
say at the moment
but i would say
you got to believe in something more
than anything else i i think also this
is sort of related to some of the
earlier questions you know we don't
believe in anything in america anymore
in a collective sense right like i don't
like the collective but like in a in a
collective sense like what's pushed
forward in culture and if you listen to
joe biden and you listen to our
politicians it's just that government is
everything and give these people things
and they know how we should live and if
you don't you're a racist and a bigot
and everything else and it's like we
never talk about where god fits into
that or belief fits into that and i
believe that the people that came before
me whatever your whatever your religion
is whatever your ethnic traditions are
you know the people that came before you
probably knew a little something and
just because we all have iphones and we
all have ipads and we're going to the
metaverse it doesn't mean that we're
really evolving in any better way are we
that much happier are we that much more
fulfilled or any of that i'm not so sure
so that's helped me reconnect to some of
my family's traditions um and and that
belief you cannot have you can't
organize a society without belief i
don't think you can um
and
that's all i'll say about that right now
lisa says do you think it's possible
that china deliberately released covet
19 any country that would starve to
death 42 million people wouldn't have
much of a problem releasing a virus uh
it is an excellent trial run in
preparation for a virus that is really
deadly yeah look i don't want to sound
like a crazy conspiracy theorist because
that just means i'll be right in two
years um but yes it would not surprise
me i think there's a lot of evidence
pointing towards the lab leak theory
which you know we weren't allowed to
talk about a year ago that now most
people seem to accept so i don't know
anything that you don't know but i think
that there's certainly evidence to point
to that and that yes we were doing
research the nih funded in part by
fouchy was doing research on mrna
vaccines there mrna technology
so would it be possible though that
china would unleash this thing to then
get
our own governments led by idiots like
justin trudeau like these people who
have these really terrible
authoritarian tendencies to destroy our
own societies is that such a crazy leap
relative to everything going on could
china have really been playing a long
game here and said boy we don't need to
invade canada and america with tanks we
can get them to destroy their own
societies and shred up their founding
documents and crush their own
dissent and free speech we can get them
to do it by themselves with a little bit
of a cold
does that sound totally nuts to you
skye says as someone who has been on the
left why do you think leftists continue
to dominate the culture when
conservatives are the majority i mean
partly this is changing right now it
really is i mean there's nothing good
coming out of the left right now they've
wrecked comedy you go through netflix
it's all crap when's the last time you
saw a good movie i i yes i've heard
spider-man spider verse or spider 2 or
i'm coming home or whatever it's called
i've heard it's good it's coming out on
apple tv in a couple weeks i'll watch
okay fine but like everything is pretty
much crap they destroyed star wars
the leftism destroys things because it
doesn't believe in the individual and
the individual is the root of all
creativity right so as it's destroyed
things i do think the things that are
more funny now are conservative leaning
things uh or it's just just not woke
things but the reason that they
dominated culture for so long was
because i think
conservative people were out there
building things and doing things and
creating uh real things while they were
really focused on you know hollywood and
comedy and whatever and there there's
value in that like i love that stuff
when it's done right of course um but i
think it was just a different direction
that people went because of the way they
were wired to some degree kevin says are
you taking a security team with you to
la remember those people are crazy and
dangerous uh michael my producer who's
sitting right over there he will be
joining me and uh
is he trained in anything uh we'll have
to find out if michael's trained and he
doesn't strike me as
well i could be in a lot of trouble
we'll see
adam says dave are you hopeful that we
are going to make it to the midterms and
have a chance to vote these clowns out
before the fascist machine destroys
american freedom and liberty yes i am
hopeful i am hopeful because if i was
not hopeful i could not do what i do
and you have to be hopeful too and
humans have lived through bad things and
david beat goliath and i think we can
beat joe biden or whatever machine it is
behind him and that is partly that we
have to mock the hell out of them we
have to build new things we have to not
forget the past and
pretty much all the stuff that i talked
about today this is a good set of
questions you guys mixed it up i'm proud
of you
in closing don't forget guys you can
pre-order don't burn this country at
daverubin.com book where we have all the
links you can get it on amazon you can
get at barnes noble we have link
to some local bookstores as well if you
want to submit questions for our next q
a reuben report.locals.com and part
three of my interview with harriet
hageman who is the republican running
against liz cheney in wyoming is up on
youtube and rumble and ad free the full
thing at rubincourt.logos.com
that was a lot of talking have a nice
day